[Musique]
pour changer en amour notre
amourette il s'en serait pas fallu de
beaucoup mais ce jour là Vénus était
distraite il est des jours où cupide on
s'en fout
il est des jours au cupidons s'en
[Musique]
fout des jours où il joue les mouches du
coche où elle son émoussé dans le
Bou les flèches courdoises qu'il nous
décochent il est des jours où Cupidon
s'en fout il est les jours au cupil on
s'en
[Musique]
fout se consacrant à d'autres
imbéciles il n'est pas l'heure de
s'occuper de
nous avec son arc et tous ses
ustensiles il est des jours où cupides
on s'en fout il est des jours t Cupidon
s'en
[Musique]
fout on a tenté sans lui d'ouvrir la
fête sur l'herbe tendre on s'est roul
mais vous vous avez perdu la vertu pas
la tête il est des jours où Cupid on
s'en fout il est des jours où Cupidon
s'en
[Musique]
fout si vous m'avez donné toute
licence le cœur hlas n'était pas dans le
cou le feu sacré brillait par son
absence il est des jours où Cupidon s'en
fout il est des jours où Cupidon s' s'en
[Musique]
fou on est feuill à 20 fois la
marguerite
elle tomba 20 fois sur pas du
tout et notre pauvre IDIL a fait
faillite il est des jours où cupupide on
s'en fout il est le jour où cupide on
s'en fout
[Musique]
quand vous irez au bois ques
fleurettes jeune galant le ciel soit
avec
vous je n' pas cette chance et le
regrette il est des lour ù Cupid on s'en
fout il est les jours au cupidons s'en
fout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]